Top! Je suis l'une des industries française les plus florissante de ces dernières années
... le tourisme?... non non.
Je participe au rayonnement du savoir faire français
autour du globe. Et permet à l'industrie de créer chaque année plus d'emplois... Le luxe ?
...non c'est non...
il est d'usage il y a peu de dire que le commerce des bananes autour du monde était plus encadré que le mien.
...je suis je suis?
L'industrie de l'armement! c'est oui!
Moins encadré que le commerce de la banane ? Cyrusly?!
Alors déjà petites infos intéressantes
Le marché de la "défense" dans le monde, c'est plus de 100 fois le budget du maintien de la paix.
Les États-Unis atomisent clairement le marcher et reste le plus gros exportateur mondial
avec plus de 30% de parts de marcher entre 2011 et 2015.
En France, on tourne en général à 5% et autour de la 5ème place années après années
avec d'autres pays comme la Chine, l'Allemagne ou le Royaume-Uni.
Et pourquoi je peux pas être plus précis sur notre classement ?
Et bien parce que les montants des contrats sont tellement colossaux,
Qu'une simple signature peut modifier l'ordre des pays sur le podium.
Alors c'est vrai, hein, depuis des dizaines d'années en France on sait faire des armes,
Vous avez tous depuis votre naissance entendu parler : des Rafales, admiré notre superbe porte-avions;
Quand il est pas en réparation
Et bavé devant nos démonstrations de force chaque année au 14 juillet.
Même si en vrai, le seul truc intéressant le 14 juillet, c'est le défilé de la Légion étrangère,
Qui respire la badasserie, avec toute une armée qui se battait à la hache avant que ce soit cool.
Bref, on a un savoir-faire plutôt élevé en la matière, pour un pays de notre taille
Mais la vrai nouveauté depuis 2014, c'est qu'on commence à savoir les vendre.
Oui, parce qu'en fait pendant des années on a galéré à écouler notre production d'armes aux autres pays.
Mais depuis peu, et peut-être grâce à Jean-Yves Le Drian, ministre de la Défense
Super VRP et sulfateuse en chef de la signature de contrats
On cartonne un peu partout dans le monde.
Après un coup de mou en 2012 avec 4,8 milliards d'euros, les chiffres n'ont cessés de progresser
6,8 milliards en 2013, 8,2 milliards en 2014
On snipe même la seconde place du classement avec 16,9 milliards en 2015.
Et pour 2016, avec la vente récente de 36 Rafales à l'Inde et un premier contrat signé
en vue de la production de 12 sous-marins pour l'Australie,
on pourrait même exploser le record historique de 16,9 milliards d'euros de ventes militaire atteint l'an dernier.
Mais vendre des armes... c'est pas vendre des carottes, hein, ça rend moins aimable,
et en plus on a une vrai responsabilité de ce que l'on produit et à qui on le vend.
Et on pourrait se dire qu'il s'agit d'un marché immoral, indigne d'un pays qui a interdit le port d'arme
et qui se veut défenseur des libertés et des droits de l'homme.
Alors pourquoi on continue ?
Bah déjà parce que c'est essentiel au développement de notre propre stratégie de défense.
Quoi qu'on en pense, la France n'est plus aujourd'hui la superpuissance qu'elle a pu être,
Et va être de plus en plus difficile de rivaliser avec des pays de la tailles des U.S., de la Russie ou de la Chine
Au global ou en terme de budget de développement de défense.
Du coup, pour pouvoir rester à la pointe, on vend pour supporter une partie du poids des dépenses de la défense.
A titre d'exemple,
sans l'exportation dans les dernières années d'au minimum 40 Rafales fabriqués par Dassault;
et retenez bien ce nom parce qu'il est important,
toute la programmation militaire envisagée pour les années à venir
aurait pu s'écrouler faute de moyen budgétaire suffisant pour soutenir seul
plus longtemps la production en France.
On continue aussi parce que, comme on vend, on crée des emplois.
L'industrie de la défense en France pèse aujourd'hui 165.000 emplois directs et indirects
et devrait dépasser les 200.000 emplois vers 2018, grâce aux contrats récent qui ont pu être signés.
Et enfin on continue, parce qu'en restant à la pointe de la technologie
cela contribue à son rayonnement et à l'image de puissance qu'elle envoie.
Ce qui permet de vendre plus d'armes et donc de faire travailler plus de gens
et donc de rester à la pointe.
Un super cercle vertueux.
Sauf que c'est pas si vertueux que ça.
Déjà, lorsque les médias parlent de contrats, ils oublient de mentionner certaines contreparties.
Prenons le cas par exemple des ''super-contrats'' des 12 sous-marins australiens.
Nombreux sont les médias qui ont mentionnés que la somme s'élevait à 34 milliards.
Sauf que... c'est faux.
Puisqu'une partie sera reversée aux autres pays qui vont travailler sur ces sous-marins.
Ce qui laissera à la France une somme de 8 milliards d'euros.
Et attention, 8 milliards c'est moins que 34 mais c'est déjà ça,
et dans le contexte de crise actuel c'est super et on devrait pouvoir créer plein d'emploi avec tout cet argent.
...
Sauf que non, hein. C'est sans compter sur les contreparties qui sont un peu particulières.
Car si en France on fabrique des armes, on développe des technologies à vendre
entre autre pour simuler de l'emploi,
bah en Australie on achète des armes pour simuler l'emploi.
Comment ?
Et bien lorsque la France signe un contrat pareil
elle s'engage à réinvestir un pourcentage de l'argent touché
dans le pays de son partenaire commercial à titre de compensation.
C'est ce que l'on appelle les offsets.
Dans le cas de l'Australie on parle de faire construire des sous-marins en Australie
et non pas en France, ce qui permet à l'Australie de générer de l'emploi
tout en récupérant certaine technologies françaises.
Du coup, aujourd'hui la France table plus sur des emplois durables,
générés par le service après-vente,
que sur un pic temporaire dû à un besoin de production.
Alors diplomatiquement parlant, on se met bien avec tout nos clients
puisque les contrats nous engagent sur des longues durées,
pour aller jusqu'à 70 ans.
Mais en terme de création d'emploi
on est forcé contractuellement de délocaliser une partie des productions de produits
développés et conçus pour pouvoir être fabriqués en France.
Et attention, ça reste hyper positif économiquement dans le carde des sous-marins.
On parle pour le moment de 4 000 emplois de plus en France
et pas que dans l'après-vente. C'est toujours bon à prendre.
Mais pour rester attrayant il faut avoir des technologies à transférer.
Technologies qui prennent du temps et de l'argent à développer.
Argent qui s'acquière en vendant des armes et en transférant des technologies.
Le cercle paraît tout à coup un poil moins vertueux
parce qu'en plus le marché de l'armement est hyper instable
et le contrat n'est considéré comme signé que lorsque le premier acompte à été versé.
Alors en attendant, les commandes doivent être prises pour ce qu'elles sont,
c'est-à-dire du virtuel.
Les contrats s’étalant sur de longues durées
les échéanciers de paiement font de même
et un coup d'état ou un simple changement de parti politique
peut vraiment venir enrailler la machine.
C'est ce qui s'est passé avec la Pologne par exemple
qu'avait passé commande de 50 hélicoptères à Airbus,
qui a finalement annulé il y a peu
pour acheter américain,
suite au passage au pouvoir en 2015 du parti eurosceptique PIS.
Tant pis pour les investissements qu'Airbus avait pu commencer à mettre en place,
en plus c'était un contrat sur lequel la Pologne avait tout à gagner
puisqu'elle avait négocié 100% d'offsets.
Et si un simple changement de parti politique, dans un pays européen et allié, peut foutre un bordel pareil,
bah on peut être un peu stressé quand on voit que c'est l’Égypte, pays un poil instable ces dernières années,
qui est l'un de nos plus gros client.
Ça pue un peu la merde, hein, parce que si demain l’Égypte sombre dans le chaos,
que vont devenir les armes qu'on aura vendu au pays ?
C'est le problème majeur du commerce des armes à feu :
le manque de contrôle sur le business et le manque de transparence sur les échanges.
Aujourd'hui le plus gros problème en vérité c'est pas qu'on vend des armes,
c'est surtout qu'on les vend à n'importe qui.
Et la France n'est pas un super exemple
déjà pour trouver des chiffres détailler sur le marché français
faut se lever tôt,
mais parce qu'en plus, certain grand producteurs d'armes et capitaines d'industrie française
ont une certaine culture de la corruption pour acquérir de nouveaux marchés.
Mais attention, hein, le business de l'armement ne connait pas de pot-de-vin.
Ne me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas dis.
Nan, on préfère parler de frais commerciaux exceptionnels, voilà.
Ca peut atteindre jusqu'à 11% des transactions.
En Arabie saoudite, partenaire privilégié de l’État français,
le contrat pour la rénovation de la flotte, remporté par la DCNS en 1994,
les mêmes qui feront les sous-marins australiens,
ont permis de reverser 46 millions au prince sultan
et 30 millions à son frère.
Je parle évidemment pas des milliers de conflits d’intérêts
qui pourraient concerner Serge Dassault, à la fois patron de l'entreprise qui fabrique nos fameux Rafales,
PDG du Figaro, mais aussi sénateur français.
Des positions plutôt pratique pour prendre des décisions qui ne vont pas forcément dans le bon sens,
tout en évitant d'en parler dans les médias puisqu'on en contrôle une partie.
Ça doit pas aider à trouver des chiffres exacts sur le rôle de la France dans les dérives du secteur.
Ensuite on est pas un super exemple, parce que lorsque des gens, des ONG, ou des États,
tentent de calmer les problèmes provoqués par le business de l'armement,
on est pas foutu de respecter des accords que l'on a pourtant signés.
Par exemple le TCA,
c'est un traité qui va dans le bon sens,
il est entré en vigueur le 24 décembre 2014,
et ce dernier a pour vocation de réguler le commerce des armes,
vers les pays peu pointilleux concernant le respect des droits de l'homme.
Alors au passage il n'a pas été ratifié par les U.S., Israël ou les Émirats arabes unis,
comme quoi y'a des points sur lesquels ces trois là sont d'accord.
La France en revanche l'a signé et ratifié en 2014
mais ça nous a pas empêché de vendre 141 millions d'euros d'arme à l'Arabie saoudite,
peu connu pour son respect des droits de l'homme en 2015.
Mais bon, hein, histoire de ne pas faire paniquer les fan de Zemmour
on vend aussi à la Chine, pourtant sous embargo européen depuis le massacre de la place Tian'anmen.
Et c'est finalement tout le problème de la politique français, elle est pensé à cours terme.
Si demain l'Arabie saoudite souhaite soutenir un mouvement, pourtant hostile à l'occident et à la France,
ce qu'elle est suspecté de faire d'ailleurs,
qu'est ce qui l’empêche de le faire en fournissant du matériel français ?
Même si les ventes de la France vers l'Arabie saoudite se sont réduites ces dernières années,
il est peut être temps que notre pays stop une course à l'armement sans fin,
qu'elle finira probablement par être incapable de financer autrement qu'en bradant ses découvertes aux pays les plus offrants
et dans n'importe quelles conditions.
Quitte à s'engager dans une course sans fin, où les avancées technologique
seraient vendu pour financer la poursuite de la recherche
autant le faire dans une autre industrie que celle de l'armement.
Et ça tombe bien, y'a plusieurs industrie que ça pourrait concerner
dont celle de l’énergie, avec toute la transition énergétique à laquelle on assiste
et qu'on va tous être obligé de vivre si on veut pas avoir à survivre.
L'innovation et la création de l'emploie par l'armement avaient du sens à une certaine époque,
on a changé d'époque,
il est peut être temps de changer le reste.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu. N’hésitez pas à lacher un pouce ou à la partager si c'est le cas.
N'hésitez pas à me suivre sur les différents réseaux sociaux
que ce soit Facebook, Twitter ou Snapchat.
A chaque fois je les utilise de manière très différente et assez exclusive.
Donc suivez-moi.
Merci à tout les tipeeer qui soutiennent ce projet, ça me fait plaisir,
ça me touche et ça me permet d'essayer de faire des vidéos de meilleures qualités à chaque fois.
Toutes les sources et les infos sont dans la description.
On se retrouve dans quelques jours pour une nouvelle vidéo.
Love, peace... Ciao. @quasimotar